today we're
sort of bringing it all together for
thomas aquinas and
natural law theory of ethics right
we've contrasted it a couple times to
divine command theory and we're going to
talk about that a couple of
times again today by contrast
and we're going to look at
how does this actually work how do you
think about ethics in terms of natural
law
so we had part of that before we went
we just did this a minute ago we talked
about what is happiness
remember thomas went through all these
different candidates could be could it
be wealth
well no because of this reason
could it be pleasure pleasure's good
we enjoy pleasure we pursue pleasure but
that's not
happiness per se could it be
some quality of the soul like aristotle
seem to think or plato
having virtues that's good too but
that's not the whole
kit and caboodle as they say so there's
something else involved there
and then we talked about virtues and
vices
and this notion of sin and you notice he
was dealing with it
not so much as a theologian a theologian
would talk about sin
as say offense against god right what
makes something
sin god doesn't like it god tells you
don't do it
but you can also think of a sin as just
any sort of bad action
right and if you're doing that you're
not thinking in terms of
theology you're thinking as a moral
philosopher
and as we've been going through this
this semester you remember
thinking back to the mcintyre piece that
i had you read at the start
all of you are not professional
philosophers although who knows maybe
some of you will
go on and become that later on but all
of you are
moral philosophers to a certain extent
you've been thinking about
what actually does make human beings
happy not just you but other human
beings
about different ways of articulating
this
about blushing whether rules are needed
whether
certain habits are needed whether
certain conditions are required
how that would work you've been doing it
by
thinking it through some great you know
previous thinkers
sort of thinking alongside them sort of
like when you're riding a bike
you first started out riding did you
immediately hop on and
take off what did you have on your bike
at the start training wheels right
reading these texts is sort of like
training wheels for you as developing
moral philosophers so you read through
aristotle because aristotle had a lot to
say
and some of it's pretty good i think
some of you at least
see some value in it right and
eventually the training wheels are going
to come off
and you're going to be in situations
where you have to think about this
and you know unless you've been
memorizing aristotle you're not just
going to have in your mind say ah
aristotle
addressed this sort of situation let me
or
you take out the book let me see what
arizona said
because i'm in this business situation
or this policing situation
or something like that um that's
probably not going to be the case
but you'll have you know bits and pieces
that you've taken from it
things that you've made your own that's
what you've been doing with
these writing assignments you've been
contextualizing it in terms of your own
life
right that's part of why you're going to
do the resource guide because you're
contextualizing
in terms of your passion or your
profession
well all of this brings us back to
thomas so
we're bringing thomas to all these these
threats together
in this notion of the natural law
because the natural law
tells us that we need to have virtues
and to avoid vices
or if we have vices to get rid of our
vices
it directs us towards our final end or
happiness
and here's where it gets really
interesting
thomas thinks that
let's say you were stuck on a desert
island somewhere with a bunch of people
you know pick gilligan's island for
example
or those survivor shows i don't know if
they stole abandoned people on islands
or they put them somewhere else
because i can watch that show for a long
time any of you watch watch that show is
it still on the air
yeah i think it is do they still set it
like you know
some will make a remote place out of
nowhere
yeah this must be like in its 10th or
11th season
i know so imagine you're on one of these
islands right now some people would say
if you didn't bring a bible we're going
to pick any other holy book that you
want
you are just screwed when it comes to
morality
because the book tells you how you want
to behave the book is a revelation from
something greater than human beings and
if you don't
have that all bets are off
and you've probably seen some movies
or read some books in which things
happen like that right
did you guys have to read lord of the
flies back in middle school or high
school
what happened to that part we're going
to
talk about hobbs that's going to be a
little bit more like that what happened
yeah
these kids airplane professionals
they're stuck on an island are there any
adults no
so there's no moral authorities bless
you
as far as i know i don't remember them
having any questions
and what happens to their relationships
with each other how do things pan out
yeah
that's what it gets worse sometimes yeah
you're right it gets worse and in what
ways what what happens there
uh like
at first they go hunting and then uh
that's a lot of fun too right they
there's a lot of descriptions of how
great it was spearing the pigs
and they roast the pigs and have you
ever been to pig roast
that's pretty good eating all right then
at some point i'm ready to kill each
other
i might still okay
i'll come back so they're having fun
doing what boys like to do hunting that
sort of stuff and
somehow they end up ready to kill each
other and
i don't remember does piggy get killed
yeah yeah
that's right okay so how do they end up
going from here to here
yeah did this separate for like two
groups and one length or two
i think it was like a fallen pilot or
something weird i think i'm england do
you remember that
they broke into two groups that i
remember like they broke up into a
hunting group and then the guy
jacks read lies about the other ones
yeah there's there's jack and he's like
the chief bad guy
right he is the one who gets
sacrificed in the end and then what was
the name of the
guy who stands up for piggy
anyone remember ralph yeah
very good um
what is it what is ralph doing that jack
isn't doing i mean jack
leads them into some sort of yeah i
think weird idolatry
but he's also a leader
he doesn't seem to have a very strong
sense of right and wrong
or he seems to be sort of like remember
thrasymachus
hey if you can take power and use it on
other people
that's great put yourself at the top and
then you know everybody has to obey you
yeah
i think jack would be more like a sad it
would be considered like
i think that when they split into two
groups i think robert
i remember when i read it back in high
school this is all sort of ancient
history for us
isn't it yeah i should i should reread
that i haven't read it since
high school myself yeah i think you're
right
um one is
one is representing civilization and not
just civilization but
you know what goes along with
civilization morality
a sense of right and wrong something
that we teach to each other
something that we we pretend to practice
like think about this classroom right
do any of you every once in a while feel
like saying
i got other stuff to do i'm getting the
hell out of here
honestly did any of you ever feel like
that i know i did when i was in a
college class what keeps you from doing
that
or let's say there's other things you'd
like to do
maybe you'd like to be at breakfast
right now
maybe you know instead of talking about
thomas today you'd like to talk about
something else
that's on your mind
why are we you know doing things this
way we kind of have a ritual don't we
and
why do you not all talk at the same time
the users are actually very
well-mannered you raise your hands and i
i i
taught a place where students don't do
that they just shout things
okay so it's the order of things the way
things are done is there any good reason
for it
can you think of any good reason why you
should raise your hand
excuse me that's a very good explanation
so it doesn't get chaotic everyone's not
talking at the same time
and that's a good thing right in order
for learning to take place can all of
you just be sort of
talking about whatever you want at any
time
maybe if we break into small groups as
some
some do but no you're exactly right
there's a purpose to it
now uh you know what we know about
so-called primitive peoples is that
quite often they have very elaborate
social systems and
sets of rules and so
was it ralph no ralph is the civilizing
guy
jack is the we're going to be savages
right
and when civilized people turn savage
they're
way worse than any savage that we've
ever run across because what they do
is they remove that moral code they
remove that
set of expectations that we all have in
certain treatment with each other
and they don't replace it with anything
other than using power on each other
and if you actually look at you know
so-called savages
in functioning tribal societies they
don't do that to each other
except in certain cases you know often
when society is breaking down
so ralph there jack is a very different
kind of savage
than the people that they're thinking
that they like
and a lot of this comes back to this
idea of natural law
they didn't have a book to tell them
what to do
ralph didn't actually come out and say
well
the precepts of british civilization
are that we should act this way when
we're in these sort of situations
he just sort of said hey this is the
right thing to do
quit picking on piggy he's got a piggy
is this kid who's got asthma right
and so he can't do all the things that
the other kids can do
um you know don't listen to this guy
jack he's leading you astray
he's not saying these things because
he's holding a holy book in his hand
saying
and verse such and such it says this and
this
and he's not doing it based on just
english civilization
has taught me this he's saying this is
the right thing to do
and he's making a claim that this is the
right thing to do whether we're english
french american you know from
ghana from china pick wherever you want
he's appealing to something like the
natural law
thomas thinks that we have
blessings we have within us
and for some of us it may be you know
sort of obscured
and some of us it may be much more
shining through
we have a sort of innate sense of right
and wrong
that has been implanted in us by the
kind of beings that we are
so it is it is coming from the divine
but it's not coming from the divine like
a book that you you know
page through and say okay now i've read
this now i know what to do
instead it's written within our hearts
as they say
and we have to work at it to actually
bring it out and
make it operative to make it clear
it's not like you just sort of think to
yourself what's the right thing to do
and it pops right into your head you do
have to think it over
if you think about another you know
island situation with you know
gilligan's on you've all seen gilligan's
island right
a lot of what they have to do are
puzzling through certain moral
situations
should they spend their time building a
raft or fixing the radio
you know does the does the professor get
to
you know hog some of the supplies to do
this thing
should you know the howls uh be
uh generous with their their belongings
they've got a lot of things along
should the skipper be in charge since
he's actually the you know
the guy who was in charge on the boat um
how should the skipper treat his little
buddy gilligan who's kind of a
you know simpleton um
how should he keep him out of trouble
you know these are all questions about
morality these are all questions about
what one ought to do
practical reasoning and when they're
puzzling through it often they're
thinking of things in terms of the
natural law
so let's let's now think about the
notion of law itself
this is very far from what you're used
to thinking about is law
what are some examples of laws that you
can think of in our society
let me ask you this let me change the
question
where have you encountered the law
how many of you have run up against the
law
at one point or another
none of you ever had a speeding ticket
nobody has had a speeding ticket a few
people are copying
it you ran into the law right
why did they give you the ticket
because you looked at the cop the wrong
way
i think the last speeding ticket that i
had was in tennessee and i was like
coming down a mountain
and i was going at least 20 over because
you know
at night i've been driving for like
eight hours and you get going down those
mountains and you
pick up speed pretty quick and went past
the speed trap
still not supposed to be going that fast
right
you encountered the law and what does
the law say the speed limit says
you can only go from here to here
as far as your range of speed if you go
any further what does the law also say
you can be punished
um when you when they when you got your
ticket what is the ticket saying
you remember
we'll see how fast you're going what
else
and then you get a court date
and if you're if you're in another state
generally you don't go to court you just
pay the fine
just familiar where else have you run
into the law
you guys are all you know 20 21 22.
you've all worked right
what did you have to do at the end of
the year
pay taxes i mean you they probably took
it out of your paycheck i'm waiting but
most of you got a
refund back right most of the time
sometimes
sometimes yeah it depends on how much
you make and those refunds will go away
once you guys get out
it's amazing how much your your of your
money goes into taxes once you start
making money
you encounter the law on that right what
happens if you don't file your taxes
nothing
why do it what happens if you don't file
your taxes
yeah you know
you wanted it right and if they find
that you should have paid more taxes
they tack on penalties and fines and you
can even go to prison
um one of the most notorious gangsters
of all time in the united states
uh got sent to prison for tax invasion
because they couldn't
successfully prosecute him on anything
else so they
they actually took his illicit earnings
as taxable income and then charged him
with with tax invasion
al capone
how else do we encounter the law what
are some of the laws that you guys
follow
that you probably wouldn't think of
violating except maybe in extreme
circumstances
none of you are killers right anybody in
here who's
if you were you wouldn't tell me
anybody killing people off on the side
probably not
why not
we happen to see if you kill somebody
and you get caught
what are the ramifications yeah
jail not just jail well jail first
then they'll try you and then if you're
found guilty where do you go
worse than jail prison
yeah jail is for short timers
misdemeanors
prison is where you you stay
interestingly prison is not always the
worst place to be
bernie madoff you guys are all familiar
with you know the
ponzi scheme king he wrote a book
recently where he says that he's happier
now in prison than he that he's been in
20 or years 20
he's happier now than he's been in the
last 20 years
which you know we could think about i'm
going to sort of
pass over that so you guys encounter the
law
we tend to think of laws in terms of
particular
parts of the code right you have to do
this you have to do this you can't do
this
you have the right to do this but only
in this way
we often don't think about what is law
and what's its purpose
why do we have all these laws
why do we have speed lines that's that's
what i think
at one time we didn't have speed limits
what would happen if we didn't have
speed limits like we were right right
over here on uh
nine let's say what's the speed limit's
like 40 in parts of it and 30 i think in
other parts
let's say we get rid of that what would
happen
a lot more accidents and why would that
happen
yeah people would be driving like
maniacs in the morning some of you who
commute
and come up nine from the south you know
that
when you get past the uh the exit for
the
bridge how fast are our cars going it's
40 miles an hour there
if you want to keep up with traffic how
fast are you going
not 70 or 80 it's not chicago but
but 60. so people are routinely going
20 hours in there that's with speed
limits actually in place
so if we didn't have any there there'd
be some people driving down that road
100 miles an hour
and then you know there'd be danger
there'd be accidents there'd be danger
to life
so what's the purpose of the law in that
case
what's the law doing for us
to contain people's actions
so notice now for the safety and good of
people in society
we're talking about a good safety is a
good it's a good that makes other goods
possible
um for any law that's in place if it's
if it's a decent law you can say what is
its purpose
what is the good that it's aiming in and
something else that ms ren
brought up is very important society is
the law just for the the good of me
it's for you too is it just good for us
it's good for everybody out there that's
what we call a common good
it's you you're supposed to be
legislating for the common good
and now this isn't in the readings that
i assigned to you but actually
this guy used by martin luther king this
very
notion of natural law and the nature
of what a good law is got used by martin
luther king in his letter from the
birmingham jail
the law that he was in jail for breaking
was
against it was it was a law regulating
public assembly and having parades and
marches and stuff like that without a
permit
and the reason the law was put in place
was
not for the common good it was put in
place
to keep african americans in the south
the segregated south
from being able to carry out protest
marches
and try to you know change the situation
of segregation
now that was a law that was working out
just fine for some people in that
society the people who wanted to you
know stay in control
which was not the the entirety of all
whites too by the way
in say alabama right it was
those who were deriving something from
having this very strict racial division
certainly wasn't for the good of other
people in that society was it
was to their detriment and what he said
is
a law that does that sort of thing
that doesn't lift up humanity but
degrades humanity
is a bad law and where was he getting
that from two people
thomas aquinas and somebody else that
aquinas
uh used as well uh saying augustine
so you know augustine says the law
that's not for common good
is a bad law and it's not really a law
at all and thomas follows him in that
a law has to be ordained for the good
not just of
the law giver but for the good
of those who are governed by it
think back again to thracinicus what was
thrasymachus saying
you know the rulers they just arrange
things to their own benefit
and they put laws in place that will
benefit them
like let's say i i let's say i was a bad
teacher batted in the moral sense not
you know the pedagogical sense
i demanded it all of you in order to get
a good grade
you all have to pay me a what should we
call it a consulting fee
or can you think of any better euphemism
because you don't want to call it a
bribe right
what do you think would be a good good
value for an annual class
left hand let's say we had to set a
dollar
i haven't thought about this because
this is the sort of thing i can do with
students
it probably hasn't crossed your mind
either has it let's say we had to pick a
dollar
hundred dollars that'd be good or maybe
five hundred dollars
you need to be guaranteed a name
what would you be willing to pay
well let's say the situation were
reversed let's say you're in my shoes
what would you charge other people
if you were in that situation
i have no idea what dollar limit to put
on
if i were doing that
i'd be you know sort of like the
legislature the legislator
governing making arrangements very
clearly to my benefit maybe to your
benefit as well if
you enjoy you know paying for grades if
that's the sort of thing you're into
would that be good would that be for the
common good
what do you think see any sort of
problem with that although that you know
you're not supposed to do that
and according to the student combat code
okay very good it's it's not ethical
because
that's the key thing because then people
aren't
doing their own work why do we make you
do work in college
just to fill up your time because you
have to do something with you or else
you you know run wild over campus
if you're not you know doing athletics
or you know involved in clubs or things
like
that right we got to keep you guys
active somehow that is that the
reasoning
why do we give you assignments
so you can demonstrate your
understanding of the work but also
before that just so you can build your
understanding right so you can
build your skills build your
competencies so you come out of here
four years later knowing a lot more than
you did at the start i mean if you're
coming out here four years later the
same person you
came in something went wrong with
college education
right again so if we had a practice like
that in place
it would not be for the common good it
would not be for the good of the
governed it wouldn't be for those
who were supposed to be taken care of
that's the nature of law
law has to be for the common good it
can't just be
the egoistic desires or interest
of the person making the laws there's
another thing
law is given by reason
it has to be rational it can't just be
i'm going to give a law just because i
feel like this
that's why legislators actually debate
the idea is
that by having multiple sides
represented
the best laws will come out of it often
that's not really the case
they just compromise you know but those
are not good laws
in that case laws are discoverable by
reason
you as rational human beings are on a
different plane than other animals are
even other really smart animals like
chimps you know you can teach chimps to
do a whole bunch of things and they seem
to imitate each other and learn from
each other
they're also one of the most violent
species too i don't know if you know
this
gorillas are not the real violent ones
gorillas are real peaceable
chimps will actually hunt down other
bands of chimps and wipe them out and
exterminate them
if they think that they're moving into
their territory
so you know you see these movies like
the planet of the apes and it's the
chips that are the nice ones and the
gorillas that are
being totally backwards right
and they're pretty smart you know they
have societies and all that
what do we have we have reason octopi
turn out to be incredibly smart
you can actually like take an octopus
and they have to they'll show it like a
video
of a hand opening a jar to get at
something inside
the octopus watches that and then
figures out how to open a jar
to get to the food inside
apparently of the the invertebrates
occupy the smartest ones and it's a good
thing that they have a very short life
cycle or else maybe they've been
you know taken over the earth and
enslaved all of us right
but we're different we have reason we
communicate with each other
we reason things out with each other we
do that about you know
very simple things we do that with
mathematics we do that with right and
wrong as well
that's again where the natural law comes
from that's how we
find out what it entails
so thomas talks about different types of
law i'm going to get to the
to that moment let's think about what
the natural law actually entails and
i put this over here as sort of a
interesting principle
this is the sort of moral guide
for a very important company that is
going to probably be involved in your
life
for the rest of your life does anybody
know which company it is
that said well here's our policy on
morality
don't be evil does anybody know which
company that is
yeah very good google
so google said well you can you can boil
it all down to this don't be
you know if everybody followed that that
would probably
be better than where we are currently
and that sounds kind of like the natural
law
but it's actually not enough
don't be evil what do you need
just to make that work right after that
yeah and do we all agree about this is
evil or that's evil some people
um consider abortion to be one of the
greatest
evils of our times just because of the
sheer number
of abortions carried out and the
status of the infant sound like you know
capital punishment where somebody's
killed somebody
in most cases there are some cases where
people get you know
executed and it turns out later on they
didn't do it those are
fairly rare some people consider that to
be a horrific evil
other people actually say it's a
positive good
i know that may sound a little strange a
lot of people see it as a necessary evil
right they say well
you know we gotta have it because
otherwise it's it's holding back women
it's part of reproductive rights or
something like that
there are some abortion rights activists
who brag about how many abortions
they've had
and see it as a rite of passage there
are some who
say i aborted my first child so i could
provide a much better life for my second
and third child
they clearly don't see that as evil do
they
so don't be evil what if you're a google
employee
and you're thinking about whether you
should have an abortion or not does this
actually give you any guidance
not much it needs to be made more
specific does it
there's another problem with it too is
it enough
to be a good person just not to be evil
what do you think let's put it in these
terms
how many of you think that down the line
you're going to get married or have some
sort of you know partner that you're
going to be with the rest of your life
like it's most of the class let's say
this is the guidance
for them and you know let's say they
work for google
or you meet him at google and you say
okay don't be evil
um now we're gonna get married and spend
the rest of our life together
here's the moral code you're gonna
follow is that enough
is that would you want to be with
somebody the rest of your life
whose moral code consists just in
avoiding
being evil you said why not
like i've been considering something
able yeah there's that there's that
problem if we don't always agree about
that
let's go past that though let's say you
actually do agree
these these are evil things we're not
going to do like say cheating right
you're not going to cheat on each other
you're not going to run up huge debts
you know without telling each other
you're not going to open up credit cards
in each other's names you're not going
to punch each other
you're not going to stick each other
with knives you run down the whole list
right you're not going to when you're
playing games
you're not going to cheat at the board
games with each other
you'll pass on each other's messages
because not
not doing that would be a very small
evil but you know it could be
could be bad you won't embarrass each
other at parties
like at christmas um all these negative
prohibitions would that be enough for
you
do we set the bar there and say i'm
going to be happy if i can deal with
somebody who
doesn't do this doesn't do this doesn't
do this doesn't do this it doesn't do
this
is that really where we set the bar is
that where were you guys
this at the bar i hope not i mean you
guys are young still so
you should you know life should not have
beaten you down so much
that you're going to settle for someone
who just doesn't
push your buttons
what else do you want out of somebody
what are you looking for in your
potential partner or spouse
okay they got to be good-looking right
we're talking about moral things what
else are you looking for
yeah oh do you ever end up
i'll go i didn't want my hand but um
someone who's actually a good person
yeah and don't be evil just gets you to
don't be an evil person it doesn't get
you to actually
be a good person what are what are some
some of the examples of traits of good
person that you're looking for
yeah respectful
okay that's that's going beyond
not being able right what else
you know somebody who's kind that's
going way beyond
not being because you can you can treat
people
and not not you know offend them or
anything like that that's not the same
thing as being kind
actually making gestures because you
show the other person that you
do in fact value them and care about
them i hope all of you want somebody
who values you and cares about you i
hope all of you get somebody like that
as a matter of fact if you wind up with
somebody who doesn't do that maybe you
should think about getting rid of them
not killing them but getting breaking up
with them right
so don't be evil by itself isn't going
to cut it what thomas talks about the
natural law
as incorporating part of that he says
the most
general precepts of the natural law that
are not you know directly applicable
but do give us some guidance good is to
be done
evil is to be avoided notice this goes
beyond just avoiding evil
not you know it's not just don't offend
people well that's gonna
be an important thing it's do good to
other people
don't just not when you have kids don't
just not screw your kids up
actually love your kids and nurture them
and help them to become good people
themselves
so this is the most general precept and
then thomas says we have certain natural
inclinations
and if we want to see the way that we
should act for the common good
then what we ought to do is think about
sort of broad metaphysical things about
being itself about what it is to be an
animal
and then what it is to be rational and
we see whether anything comes out of
that
and with what he calls the good of
nature or just sheer being or existence
everything that exists wants to continue
in its being
everything that exists does plants want
to grow and stay alive
not in the same way that we have wants
animals you know they don't understand
death quite the same way that we do
but you know if you go to a
slaughterhouse and and you see that
moment where the
pig or the cow realizes that that
somebody is killing other pigs and cows
on the line in front of it you can tell
they're not happy about that
they don't want to be there and that's
why they put chains in place and
you know push them on because
we're going to eat them you know that's
that's where it comes from right
everything that exists wants to continue
in its being
even when people want to commit suicide
they're committing suicide in general
not because they don't like life at all
but they don't like the life
that they have they consider that life
to be damaged in some way or not worth
living or you know not worthy of human
dignity or something like that they're
not
just getting you know they're not saying
life by itself is a bad
thing or existence is a bad thing now if
that's the case
what can we draw as sort of a conclusion
from that
well that means that life is valuable
maybe not just human life but even
animal and plant life as well
although not to the same extent as
humans for somebody like thomas
right so
providing and protecting for
life let's say you know we had that
example
um was it last class that i asked you
about the kid out in the middle of nine
and um cars coming
you know the lights changed you see that
kid a four-year-old out in the middle of
the crosswalk do you run out there and
grab the kid
does that was that last class we've
brought it up okay
so if you have that natural inclination
thomas would say you're actually
following the natural law
which is to protect life um
now it's not always so cut and dry as it
does that isn't
are there ways in which we could be
maybe protecting other people's lives
that depend more on our becoming
informed and making decisions
and things like that probably
and do you think that would be a good
thing to do
anybody think it would be a bad thing to
become better informed about
how the way we live our lives impinges
on other people's lives it may have been
threatened
things like that that would be a good
thing wouldn't it
again the natural law at work and we
also should
try to provide the means for life
not you know for ourselves each one of
you is valuable
and you want to consider yourself as
valuable as valuable as any other human
being
and you want to preserve your own life
and you also ought to preserve the means
for your own life what do you need in
order to live
you have certain basic requirements
shelter
food drink
what else do you need to live clean air
clothes certainly in this environment
coming out of the tropics um there's all
you know in our society which is kind of
complicated there's a lot of things
you need money don't you money or some
sort of means of support
because when you go to the store and you
say i need this can of beans
and you start walking out with it
they're
not going to let you get away with that
unless you give them something in return
but thomas actually is just kind of well
known for
looking at cases like what if you have a
parent
who's starving himself and whose kids
are starving and he's got no way of
getting money is it okay for him to take
bread without asking
to feed his family the natural law might
in some
some cases require them thomas actually
says that's not stealing
the proper description of that is taking
something
necessary to assure life following the
natural law
should we set up things in such a way
that some people
you know in our society it's you know
there is a lot of hunger
but there's also a lot of means to libya
very large support networks interlocking
is that the case everywhere
can you think of places where that's not
the case
these social networks don't exist
thomas would say we ought to think about
those sort of things
if we have the if we have the means to
provide other people with
the means for life we shouldn't withhold
them
we should actually provide them
not not necessarily everything that we
have you don't have to become destitute
yourself but we want to
he thinks this is what the natural law
requires that if we're
relatively rich which we are we want to
be
looking to other people and trying to
arrange society
in such a way that people are taken care
of
that's just one aspect um that's all
being
right animals
we have a lot in common with the animals
what do we have in common with animals
you know they're animals because we're
animals ourselves
i have reproduction up here because
that's what that's the example that
thomas brings up
what else do we have
we already covered eating and drinking
and stuff like that right
what else do animals do that plants
don't
what can you think of
imagine that you would have
you'd be stuck where your roots are
wouldn't you
animals are capable of what we call
locomotion
they can move from place to place thomas
doesn't actually talk about this
but maybe you know there's been a lot of
talk in recent years about the right to
travel the right to
to relocate the right to move from place
to place
maybe that would actually fit under the
natural law that that human beings
should not impede each other's movements
unless there's good reasons you know i
mean like let's say there's a quarantine
there's a disease that breaks down that
could be a good reason to
constrain movement or you know put
somebody in prison
you're obviously constraining the
movement but you're doing it because
they
did something horrific and you want to
try to fix them
or at least keep them out of circulation
for a while he talks about reproduction
what's involved in reproduction well you
know we have a natural inclination to
hook up
as people say to have sex
that's pretty much hardwired right if
you don't have that
there's something wrong with the brain
chemistry something's going wrong
organically
or maybe you have too much stress
there's a lot of discussions about
stress and then the
reduced libido lately now we kind of
modified
it too what sort of ads do you see on tv
where people are trying to boost
you know what sort of products do we
have out there
you can think of
somebody's commercials are quite funny
yeah a y oh yeah
i wasn't i was thinking of like pills
and stuff like that like niagara and
cialis but yeah
uh ky they're they started selling they
have con demands on tv try these condoms
because they're gonna
you know improve your life together your
intimacy
now these are kind of funny examples sex
is always funny right
um what are they getting at well
having sex is a good
why well i mean there's two sides to it
the sort of you know traditional way of
looking at it is what what happens when
you have sex
other than having a lot of fun
you make anything every once in a while
yeah babies yeah
and if we don't have babies the human
race doesn't doesn't reproduce
and then pretty soon there's no human
beings and actually if we don't produce
enough human beings given how complex
our society is
that can lead to a societal breakdown if
you have too many old people and not
enough young people
you're in a lot of trouble and you
better find some young people to come in
from somewhere else
and reproduction is a good according to
somebody like thomas he would say
yeah i mean all things want to reproduce
each other
so when those praying mantises you know
i don't know exactly
the mechanics of sex or praying
manchester's but i know that some sperm
master reached some egg somewhere then
the eggs get laid somewhere
and then they answered to a bunch of
little baby praying mantises because i'd
actually seen that
i saw a hatching you see all these tiny
little prank dances just like running
all over the yard
most of them are going to get eaten they
insects reproduce a lot
because they know most of them won't
survive we make like one or two babies
at a time because we tend to do
something else with that
which is to raise the young
right mammals are a little bit different
than most other
animals mammals what makes us mammoths
anyone know offhand certain glands
that female animals have
the the animal the mammals what's that
mammary glands and what are the what do
those do
well they're actually sweat glands they
produce a
very specialized type of fluid which we
call
what giving him we drink the cow's
version of it sometimes the goat's
version of it
some people you know milk yeah while
they're scared to take milk
no yaks or you know sheep or whatever
well that's very important that's
actually part of
raising young we don't just like you
know turtles or alligators do
lay a bunch of eggs and then get out of
town and sometimes eat the babies
afterwards
we raise them we raise them you know for
like 18 years
actually some of you probably you know
still feel kind of dependent on your
parents right
uh your parents are probably blaming you
in their tax forms and things like that
because we've extended
adolescence well that's actually part of
what thomas thinks is the way things
ought to be if you're
what we call a deadbeat dad right
somebody who say gets women pregnant
and then says ah see you later you know
that's not good you're supposed to
nurture your
you're young even if you pay the child
support
but you're not involved in the
children's lives you know from all this
empirical studies that the role of the
father
and their their relationship with the
children and their interaction with with
the children
is extremely important in how the how
the children develop
and what their outcomes in life are
there's a huge issue in our society
there's so many absent fathers
um
well thomas would say the natural law
tells you
if you're if you're a father you get
somebody pregnant
there's a baby involved who's going to
grow up into an adult human being
eventually
you ought to be involved in that
person's life and if
if having anger problems or you know
without you know a drug problem or
something like that the gambling problem
keeps you from
being able to do that you should get rid
of that problem so that you can
do what the natural law is saying you
you need to do
there's one other thing too when it
comes to sexuality what else
so we have we have pleasure and sex
right that's one reason we do it
one reason we desire babies come from
sex what else can come from sex
good things so not you know diseases
depression you know things like that
what are some good things that can come
from sex
what else are people looking for when
they have sex not just pleasure
usually not just babies what else are
they looking for
why do people hook up with each other
yeah like
creates a deeper connection between
people
very good it creates a deeper connection
the word that we often use to describe
this is intimacy
which is two people becoming
somehow fused together getting to know
each other
this is why you know it's hard to have
intimacy with a person who's not a good
person
although intimacy can sometimes steer
them towards becoming a good person
thomas would say there's two main
purposes
to to sex one is
having kids generating kids
another would be to foster intimacy
between the
people involved this may require certain
things can you have intimacy
if you're having sex indiscriminately
with anybody that you come across
what do you think can you be just as
intimate with each one of them
have a deep abiding connection of souls
probably not right um
that's i i don't i don't see how that's
going to happen
um could you do it in an abusive
relationship
let's say you've got a kind of
relationship with one person we talked
about is
friendships right sometimes friends the
relationships are just about using each
other
um let's say you have one partner who
you know is genuinely looking out for
the other partner but the other partner
is just a user
can you develop intimacy then you can
certainly have children
do you think you can develop intimacy
what do you think maybe if that's the
case then what would the natural law
tell you
get out of that kind of relationship
find somebody better for yourself
if you see somebody else in that sort of
relationship maybe the national law
would tell you
you should tell them this is not good
for you this is not what human beings
are made for
there's something better out there a new
possibility
that you haven't even seen let's leave
that aside now we'll look at the last
part of the natural log or the last sort
of
main precept of the natural law rational
beings
so how are we different from the other
animals
well we have cell phones gyms don't
right we wear clothes
gyms don't plus we dress them up
are these the things that really set us
apart as rational beings
what do you think we play soccer
gyms don't play football
we watch football we care about football
and then we talk about me
jumps don't but that's not what makes us
really rational
although actually sports could actually
figure into this and clothing could in a
certain way
what is the good for rational beings
beyond you know all these other great
things like staying alive
and reproducing and developing intimacy
and making you know children and all
that
well it's learning truth
the good for a rational being is
learning the truth of things like for
instance learning who you actually
are you guys are in the process as
college students
figuring out you know being here's the
good news
you don't have to get it completely
right while you're in college here's the
bad news
you're going to be doing it the rest of
your life because you're not going to
get to the final answer until
till the end of your life but you're
figuring out who you are the truth
of who you are you're figuring out
what's good for you
that's a matter of not just goodness but
truth
you're learning all sorts of disciplines
the things that you're learning you know
whether it's
you know medicine or criminal justice
those are good things learning those
those disciplines acquiring those skills
is a good it's true and then there's
living in society
this is different too i mean chimps
let's take the example again
chimps do live in little tiny societies
chimps don't get much beyond the family
unit
the extended clan we human beings do
very very few of us actually live in
small tiny
clan-like units
almost all of us live in much larger
societies
so those are good things those are
things that we actually desire
remember aristotle said human beings are
social
creatures thomas thinks that as well
so what do you have to do in order to
attain these these sort of goods
well you know avoiding ignorance for one
thing
choosing not to be ignorant about things
when it comes to
this project that you're involved in
right here
learning truth what should college
really be about
this came from a conference where we had
debates about what should college really
be about what should
university education be about
what are you getting out of being here
you're paying a lot for it or somebody's
paying a lot for it
um probably having some fun
and that fun may or may not be related
to your classes i don't know
ideally it should be related to your
classes shouldn't it
and you should come out here like i said
a little bit earlier a much smarter
person somebody who has much more
sustained deep contact with truth
than you came in originally and you
should actually be able to communicate
that to other people
and if you're doing that you are
actually realizing the good
of rational beings you are realizing
what it means
to be human avoiding ignorance
uh not offending other people
you know we we sometimes do like to
offend other people i know i went
through
when i was a kid
we messed with each other a lot you know
we do all sorts of gasoline things like
coming up behind each other
and you get a sharp pencil and you poke
the other kid with a pencil
what were we thinking we call each other
all sorts of names
so much that the other kid takes a swing
at you then you get to take a swing at
them
right you know the natural lot tells us
that's not a good thing to do
those are bad things to do you know
if you know that somebody has certain
buttons you probably shouldn't be
pushing those buttons
if you know somebody has an anger
problem should you keep poking at it i
remember one kid
this is kind of a shameful thing we
picked on this kid
so mercilessly this is in like eighth
grade gym class
he actually he lost it it was cool and
he picked up a baseball bat and just
started swinging
and if he would have hit somebody he
probably would have killed him
that was a terrible thing to do to that
kid we we put him in a situation
where he snapped um
you know the natural law would have told
us if we were consulting and if we were
thinking this sort of thing through
instead of
going to sort of a crowd mentality
knock it off this is bad you are
screwing up human nature by doing this
you're not realizing what it is to be a
human being you're actually doing the
wrong
thing in these sort of cases that's what
it would have told us
and it can tell people that sort of
thing in many circumstances
you know if we think we'll actually end
on this
if you think about sports right
what some of you are doing sports ethics
as your your your project for this class
that's really great
um because there's a lot of good things
about sports and there's a lot of bad
things about sports well let's think
about sports at a really high level
right where
the athletes are getting paid a lot of
money what are some of the the good
things about sports
what are people getting out of sitting
together watching a football game
or a soccer game most of the world's
watching soccer
football right what are people getting
out of that
i can tell you what i get out of it
does any of you watch sports games
what do you get out of it yeah
fun but you're not just watching it all
by yourself right
pleasure that pleasure again
i mean you you get that you get as much
of that just watching it totally on your
own
as watching it with a few friends
what do we get out of so what are we
getting out of that that experience of
watching with rice
you're just like really watching say
you're watching a football game with a
bunch of
like people in the same room for the
same team it's like
yeah very good i mean that's that's part
of the element of friendship on a
certain level
these are friendships of pleasure you
know to be fun
and pleasure so it's not you know you're
not becoming virtuous by watching
you know the vikings play the packers or
something like that right
or manchester united play whoever i
can't think of any other teams
but you are engaging in society you are
doing something that's actually good for
a crew watching you know movies together
is a good thing
it doesn't mean that it's by itself
automatically good and everything about
sports becomes
wonderful as a result but if you were
going to think about this you could say
what is the good of sports okay
it shows what human beings can become
physically
also mentally because you know if it's a
team sport they have to coordinate
it can produce these sort of
commonalities these experiences of
pleasure and fun that bring us together
that unite us
those are good things what takes away
from that
maybe maybe paying athletes these
enormous salaries that that tend to tick
people off
maybe that actually goes against that if
that's the case what would the natural
law say
that's probably not a good idea
or sending athletes on this pedestal and
you know
saying well they can do what we want in
society
clearly not going to be good for society
right
but there's many aspects of sport that
are very good for society
this is something actually has taken me
a while to learn on my own
because i was i was you know sort of
like it's all bad you know just promotes
kind of a
again mob mentality i i had to think
about this myself
over time and change when i saw it
so this will be where i am how do you
actually see the natural law working out
you use reason to figure it out you also
rely on your own experience when you see
people screw up
their lives or each other's lives by
handling sex badly
you're actually learning something about
the natural law when you
see people do really well with living
together in society
you say i want to be like that or you
see people doing a really bad job with
it you say
we've got to knock that off you are
learning about the natural law
so that's where we'll leave